puis à 11h10 très exactement à vrai dire
on avait tous un petit peu oublié il a
fait bien laid sur paris avec de la
neige aujourd'hui ce qui n'a d'ailleurs
rien d'exceptionnel nous rappelle la
météo il paraît que c'est un jour de
mars le 2 mars 1946 qui a été établi le
record absolu d'enneigement en région
parisienne il allait j'ai également
normandie d'où viennent ces images et
dans d'autres régions du pays alors tout
de suite
laurent broomhead en assurés nous est-ce
qu'il va continuer à faire mauvais en ce
moment un français secoué la petite rose
pour vous aider voici j'ai ma petite
fleur pour montrer que l'hiver était
exceptionnellement doux et finalement ça
contraste avec le temps d'aujourd'hui
pourquoi ce froid et bien parce que de
l'air très froid circulent de la russie
jusqu aux îles britanniques et les
vagues de pluie qui ont traversé la
france fière aujourd'hui du sud vers le
nord sont venus buter contre cet air
froid donnant de la neige au nord de la
seine et de la loire demain
malheureusement le temps de s'améliorer
caire sur la moitié nord du pays
beaucoup de nuages une ligne de nuages
dans le centre ici est un tourbillon
centre à peu près ici l'air tournera
comme ceci alors regardez sur la moitié
sud l'est reviendra plus tôt de l'ouest
attend donc un peu plus doux mais avec
toujours beaucoup de nuages des averses
de pluie est tout de même quelques
éclaircies dans la région
méditerranéenne moitié nord le contraire
de l'air venant de l'est beaucoup plus
froid des gelées jusqu'à moins deux mois
trois dans le nord-est des risques
certains de verglas au nord de la seine
un ciel très nuageux beaucoup d'averses
de neige avec toutefois un peu de pluie
mais laisser le temps de demain samedi
bien ma foi le tableau ne change guère
avec simplement un petit redoux sur la
moitié nord en particulier le soir sur
la bretagne ont une vague de pluies
devraient arrivés par l'ouest s'annonce
pour dimanche
un peu plus de pluie à un retour au nord
de la seine partout ailleurs un temps
toujours à ses frais tout de même un
petit peu moins désagréable que demain
et après-demain bien le temps est en
partie responsable d'un phénomène plutôt
inhabituelle en france ce moment en tout
cas la baisse d'un certain nombre de
produits veux parler des fruits et
légumes les consommateurs ne s'en
plaignent pas mais les producteurs si
l'hiver n'a pas été très rude et les
marchandises se retrouve donc en
abondance les prix baissent ou en tout
cas ne monte pas et les producteurs qui
ont manifesté ce matin à rallier
mais aussi dans d'autres villes de
province ici marseille voient leurs
revenus diminuent nous avions il ya
quelques années pour une salade paient 9
litres de fuel maintenant une salade
paye à peine un demi litre de fioul
voyez-vous pourquoi une ode exploitation
maintenance sont au bord de la faillite
les grossistes eux ont également vu
leurs charges augmenter et cette année
il se retrouve avec plus de marchandises
que d'habitude une marchandise
périssable qu'ils ne peuvent pas stocker
et qu'ils ont du mal à écouler pour eux
la crise a plusieurs causes nous avons
en premier une très mauvaise information
et là je vous attaquerez directement
mais ça serait trop long d'épilogué là
dessus nous avons un changement du mode
de vie des ménagères nous avons
également les conditions climatiques qui
font que parfois il ya surproduction et
puis nous avons aussi les contraintes
administratives qui sont lourdes et qui
empêchent des toits de commercialiser
certains produits d'investissement
enfin les détaillants ils sont également
moroses et si l'approvisionnement ne
leur pose pas de problème au contraire
ils ont de plus en plus de difficultés à
vendre leurs marchandises
nous avons l'impression que cette année
l'exportation n'a pas marché et qu'en
plus de la marchandise destinée à
l'exportation nous nous prononçons
d'achat intérieur avec des quantités
très importantes de légumes très bon
marché et de plus nous nous apercevons
que malgré ses bas prix
et bien nos ménagères ou une tendance à
diversifier leur consommation et que
nous venons de moins en moins de fruits
et légumes
voilà pour le constat essayons
maintenant de voir ce qui se passe
halfen la chaîne c'est-à-dire chez le
consommateur est bien laurent massardier
s'est mise à la place à sa place il a
pris son petit cabas et s'en est allé
faire son marché dîner prévu ce soir
pour quatre un poteau
de carottes navets de paco pas trop
grosse dans les carottes et pommes de
terre oui combien j'en prends ça comme
on peut en mai une hydre et procap été
bonne dit oui elles sont un peu quoi
quel prix les 240 et celles ci prennent
d'ailleurs la bintje d'accord docs sont
les moins chères saluer chers alors ils
disent ah vous fait éviter 10 14 4 5 lui
a non mais t'es trompé ça fait 11 40 ans
40 comme des soeurs oui alors quelques
oranges vais vous donner une bonne livre
une question celles qui sont les plus
juteuses
ah ça c'est très bon c'est de la
sanguine à 4 81 kg saviez vous elles
sont d'espagne deux matches comme ça ça
reste un bon 4 81 kg oui alors vous
donner une ligne oui qu'est-ce que
d'autres y a pas encore les fruits
rouges qui sont arrivés racim alors
défendu les frais en californie alors là
on est fou on n'est plus dans le dans
les coûts des prix là non et voilà c'est
cela qui est curieux malgré la baisse de
certains produits ou en tout cas la
stabilité les consommateurs ne se ruent
pas sur les fruits et légumes ils
boudent les produits frais cela peut
s'expliquer par un changement
d'habitudes concept est depuis plusieurs
mois par les spécialistes il est sûr que
les habitudes alimentaires sont en train
d'évoluer mais qu'il ya aussi les
habitudes global de vie des français qui
change
nous mangeons bien plus à la cantine ou
au restaurant d'entreprise qui a
quelques années et hommes et femmes nous
travaillons bien plus c'est qu'il ya
quelques années aussi et le soir bien
souvent il faut retrouver des plats
qu'ils puissent être faits rapidement
qu'ils puissent quand même aussi apporté
le petit côté personnalisés
chaque ménagères et c'est pour cela que
l'on retrouve tout à la fois un
développement des produits présentés en
surgelé qu'il s'agisse prenons un
exemple des épinards
plus personne aujourd'hui ne va trier
des kilos et des kilos d'épinards alors
que avec 350 grands bouts 500 g de
surgelés on a un plat conséquent et
c'est pour cela aussi que l'on voit le
développement des fonds de tarte pâte
brisée ou pas de sable et qui permettent
des plats nouveau préparé par le
consommateur directement chez lui
si je vous parlais tout à l'heure à
l'aide d'une brosse et que j'en trouve
el hani que termine demain une enquête
danser la vie à 18h30 consacré
précisément prix des fleurs il avait
découvert que cette rose qui s'achetait
à deux francs sur la côte d'azur se
revendaient à 12 cents à paris il y
avait là un problème je vous incite donc
à regarder le dernier c'est la vie
consacrée au sujet demain à 18h30 vie
pratique toujours trop de petits chèques
disent les banques
et voilà qu'on reparle à nouveau d'une
taxation de ces petits chèques
rien n'est encore décidé mais plusieurs
grandes banques privées s'efforce
actuellement de dissuader leurs clients
de payer leurs petits d'achat avec un
chèque signé un chèque est devenu un
acte d'une telle banalité que l'on
oublie l'énorme machine administrative
derrière doit traiter ce petit bout de
papier
ici par exemple au cic ils passent tous
les jours sur cette table entre 300 et
800 mille chèque une partie bien sûr du
total des mouvements bancaires puisque
chaque jour 10 millions de chèques
change de mains li millions de chèques à
vérifier classé comptabilisés et que
doit digérer tout un système
informatique
merrett au hasard cette machine et
regardons le montant de ces faits 82
francs 80 francs sous 114 francs 64 ans
63 points le hasard est bien fait on
constate au premier coup d'oeil
de plus en plus de clients signe des
chèques pour payer leurs cigarettes ou
presque
actuellement un chèque sur deux est
inférieure à 200 francs 1 sur 3
inférieur à 100 francs 1 sur 10
inférieur à 50 francs résultat les
banquiers grogne traiter un chèque du
style coût de 3 à 5 francs il faut que
nos clients comprennent qu'ils doivent
faire un effort
sinon un jour ou l'autre les petits
chèques seront payants
qu'est ce qui se passe quand les
services sont gratuits pour les clients
particuliers mais trop coûteux pour
l'avant et bien ce sont les emprunteurs
qui paye la différence
et dieu sait que les taux du crédit à
l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas bon marché
qu'est ce que c'est pas un peu
surprenante même de réfléchir au moment
vous réfléchissez à cette tarification
des petits chèques
parce que quand on dépose l'argent à
votre banque c'est un jour l'un fait
travailler ses deux rapports de l'argent
non plus vous pensez faire payer les
déposants
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
croient ce n'est pas nous les vents qui
fixons le taux de rémunération des
dépôts
c'est le ministère de l'économie qui le
visent
alors si le ministère de l'économie
décide qu'il faut rémunérer les dépôts
des clients
eh bien on verra mais ce n'est pas nous
qui pouvons prendre une telle décision
les organisations de consommateurs
proteste contre ces projets mais elle
semble peu suivis par leurs adhérents la
campagne de boycott contre le crédit du
nord qui a décidé l'an dernier une
certaine forme de taxation du petit
chèque le s'est traduite par la
fermeture d'une dizaine de comptes
voilà comme chaque soir maintenant le
point sur la marée noire
on a travaillé d'arrache-pied
aujourd'hui entre l'île grande et perros
guirec 15 cents militaires et 300
chauffeur d'engin divers profite du fait
qu'en de marennes n'ont rien aggraver
les vents d'est qui ont soufflé
aujourd'hui par rafales ont sensiblement
amélioré la situation dans la baie de
saint brieuc
même chose dans le finistère à
l'exception de quelques plaques de
goudron à carantec locquirec et primel
au large
le sous-marin chargé de contrôler
l'épave du tanio n'a pas pu travailler
les grèves dans l'enseignement à nouveau
des manifestations aujourd'hui à paris
des chiffres varient de 4000 à 35 mines
selon les sources le choisirait celui
qui vous intéressent il s'agissait de
réclamer pour l'enseignement secondaire
cette fois un service public d'éducation
de qualité
ces manifestations étaient surtout
accompagné de grève
51 % de participation chez les
enseignants dit le ministère le snes
syndicat national de l'enseignement
secondaire parle-lui de 80 à 100 % de
grévistes les milieux modérait de
l'enseignement par exemple le snalc font
aussi part de leur mécontentement
dominique laurie fait maintenant pour
nous le point de cette semaine de grève
et il s'est installé dans un endroit où
il était facile de trouver de la place
cet après midi une classe le point
d'encre après ces journées de
manifestations et grèves
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui est bien
pour être franc les choses n'avancent
guère les deux parties campent sur leurs
positions tout en avançant les chiffres
mais les chiffres hélas incontrôlable le
ministre de l'éducation déclare il n'y
aura pas de suppressions de postes les
syndicats répondent c'est faux c'est une
contre vérité
mais comme ces suppressions auront lieu
qu'à la prochaine rentrée
si suppression il ya allez savoir qui
dit la vérité
ce qui est certain en revanche c'est que
la grogne des enseignants est de plus en
plus forte même disons si elle est
teintée de considération politique prime
sur les mauvaises conditions de travail
sur les salaires souvent modestes vous
le savez à propos de l'histoire qu'on a
tendance à négliger de la dictée qu'on a
supprimé et des mathématiques qui écrase
l'ensemble du programme
à la vérité le conflit sur les
suppressions de poste n'a fait disons
que déborder une coupe déjà bien plein
et c'est dangereux car à moyen terme
c'est le blocage du système éducatif
dangereux aussi
car si l'agitation continue les rapports
parents enseignants qui sont
actuellement assez bon risque de se
détériorer et dangereux bien sûr car au
bout du compte dans ce type de conflit
ce sont toujours les mêmes les écoliers
qui finissent par craquer et quand
l'élève laurie parle de suppressions de
postes il parle bien entendu de
suppressions de postes d'instituteurs et
bien précisément les insulteurs du sni
on t'arrête aujourd'hui le principe
d'une nouvelle grève nationale au début
du troisième trimestre si rien ne change
d'ici là et puis demain c'est
l'enseignement libre
il va bouger politique toujours la faire
marcher avec la fin du comité central du
parti communiste à ivry près de paris
georges marchais
développer sa contre attaque fort du
soutien de tout son comité central
je n'ai pas été un agent de moscou at il
répondu à ceux qui s'intéressaient de
trop près à son emploi du temps
de 1955 et pour le reste il a dénoncé ce
qu'il appelle le complot anti communiste
de la bande des 3 vous traduire à une
énorme opération a été fabriqués et
lancés avec des moyens considérables
il s'agit je le déclare en pesant bien
le mot d'un pont clos contre le parti
communiste français et contre son
secrétaire général tout le temps
politique raisonnable n'est ce pas qui
réfléchit sérieusement sur la base des
textes et des documents ne peut manquer
d'arriver à cette conclusion de
l'existence réelle d'une banque d'une
bande des trois et deux ponts jurés
comme nous disons de l'anticommunisme
c'est évident georges marchais qui a
donné à cette conférence un espace et
spectaculaire d'un copain guy georges
marchais a parlé d'abord entouré des
membres du secrétariat du parti
communiste et puis au début de sa
conférence il a demandé aux journalistes
s'ils accepteraient que l'ensemble des
membres du comité central viennent
assister à cette conférence de presse
pour qu'on puisse éventuellement leur
poser des questions puisque un certain
nombre d'entre eux avait été mis en
cause
mais je crois que c'était surtout pour
montrer et l'unanimité du comité central
autour du proc du secrétaire général du
parti alors la bande des trois nous
avions promis de traduire ça c'est 28
une enquête
et bien c'est valéry giscard d'estaing
et jacques chirac et françois mitterrand
éventuellement michel rocard si c'était
lui qui était candidat car georges
marchais l'a souligné il s'agit d'un
complot le complot c'est un complot
politicien en vue de l'élection
présidentielle
attaqué dans son passé dans sa vie
personnelle georges marchais a répondu
en citant des documents en citant des
témoignages mais il a surtout contre
attaquer sa contre attaque est avant
tout une contre attaque politique qui
comme le complot qu'il dénonce se situe
elle aussi dans la perspective des
élections présidentielles et c'est une
contre attaque tous azimuts pour georges
marchais lyell parti communiste face à
tous les autres qui sont ligués contre
le parti communiste et pour charge le
marché il ya le parti communiste avec
son honnêteté
et en face la boue la boue des
manoeuvres politiciennes alors vous
parlez pas l'essentiel tout le monde a
envie de savoir ce que ferait le pc au
second tour s'il était distancé par le
lien et c'est à prédire une question que
l'on se pose de plus en plus car s'il
est vrai que pour georges marchais
désormais la frontière politique
principal n'est plus entre la droite et
la gauche mais entre le parti communiste
et la droite avec laquelle complète le
parti socialiste on peut se demander si
un jour il en arrivera pas la formule
valéry giscard d'estaing jacques chirac
françois mitterrand c'est bonnet blanc
et blanc bonnet après tout aujourd'hui
georges marchais les places tous les
trois dans la même bande c'est à dire
aussi dans le même sac
alors l'année prochaine arrivera-t-il à
les placer tous les trois sous le même
bonnet oui françois mitterrand dans la
rose est le symbole
je vous donne cette rozehnal unique
simone veil est la bonne elle doit être
reçue demain par helmut schmidt
elle se veut constructive et a dénoncé
la résignation un éventuel échec du
prochain conseil européen de bruxelles
nous pouvons nous en satisfaire at elle
dit pour la 38e fois depuis la fin de la
guerre nouvelle crise en italie comme
prévu le gouvernement de francesco
cossiga a démissionné hier après le
passage de républicains et de socialiste
dans l'opposition principaux motifs de
cet échec l'incapacité du gouvernement à
résoudre le problème du terrorisme mais
aussi les difficultés économiques que
connaît le pays l'italie compte un
million cinq cent mille chômeurs plus
exposés encore en france puisque
certains ne touchent même pas de limites
et regardez l'exemple de naples d'où
revient victor vraiment à naples même
les chômeurs ont droit de somptueuses
funérailles les voisins les amis se
cotise il faut réunir un million de lire
5 me fera pour avoir droit à huit
chevaux
au conseil municipal de naples et quel
que soit l'ordre du jour on parlera
forcément du chômage qui concerne entre
10 et 15% de la population active
nous sommes et vous avez dit un jour
dans une émission des dossiers de
l'écran qu'il existait en italie des
chômeurs qui ne recevrait pas
d'indemnités
comment est ce possible si bien possible
puisque c'est comme ça il y as pour les
ch'tis chante dans un travail qui
viennent du 100 licenciés ils ont
pendant trois mois ou
et encore trois mois maximum 6 9 mois et
jean tu payes des acacias mais tous les
autres manquent pas de location le jeune
par l'homme qui n'ont pas le travail et
qui ont qui n'ont pas trente ans et qui
n'ont jamais travaillé ils sont nombreux
nous avons ici
quarante mille inscrits d'analystes et
bien sûr elles n'ont rien à dire si l'on
parle je ne sont pas pris au travail
soit même des fonds sont précaires ils
n'ont rien il ya ceux qui sont victimes
de licenciements économiques crise dans
un secteur par exemple et cela reçoivent
80 % de leur salaire
mais les autres et ce sont les plus
nombreux touche 800 lire c'est à dire 4
francs par jour plus de francs par
enfant et 55 centimes par parents à
charge
ces indemnités sont perçues pendant six
mois au maximum pour vivre on travaille
de jour par 6 3 jours par là
cet homme à 39 ans il est au chômage
depuis huit ans il a 9 en francs non ils
ne touchent plus d'indemnités de chômage
il travaille de temps en temps comme
maçon pendant quelques jours et puis il
attend une nouvelle occasion de
travailler
inutile de lui demander comment il fait
vivre sa famille il n'en sait rien lui
même j'ai remarqué une chose en venant
ici c'est que autour du palais il ya
beaucoup de policiers et de carabiniers
alors vous êtes protégé contre qui jean
par région filtrant les gens qui
viennent et c
parce que il faut nous voulons que j'ai
qui viennent montrent au moins qui sont
parce qu'avant il est entré comme dans
un moulin
ce n'est pas que vous ayez peur que ce
palais soit envahie par les chômeurs il
a été surveillé par le chemin mais je
n'ai pas que nous avons peur nous avons
dans notre vie aux enfants venus de
l'etchemin manifestent pratiquement
chaque jour à naples aux cris du travail
du travail on est chômeur pendant des
années et sans indemnité il suffit
d'aller en prison au moins on travaille
en prison alors que dehors
moi je fais le mannequin quand on
appelle il ya longtemps que les
manifestations de chômeurs n'intéresse
plus personne à naples on a envie de
dire avec résignation futurs chômeurs
éviter au moins les familles nombreuses
yougoslavie alors que les autorités
règlent toujours les cérémonies qui
suivront son décès voilà que le maréchal
tito est sorti quelques instants du
commun reconnaissant même aujourd'hui
c'est vite proche orient un an après la
signature du traité de paix
israélo-égyptien reste toujours l'abcès
palestiniens les négociations entre
israël l'egypte et les etats-unis cours
est à l'échec
aussi ce sont des sommets séparé carter
begin et carter sadate qui se tiendront
dans la seconde quinzaine d'avril à
washington et je pense que nous aurons
un témoignage de poids avec la présence
lundi soir dans cartes sur table à 20h30
de cyrus vance le saut cadettes
américain il sera donc l'invité de
jean-pierre elkabbach et d'alain duhamel
la chine bouge à nouveau aucune
manifestation spectaculaire mais depuis
un certain temps des signes qui montrent
que le pouvoir est en train d'évoluer et
peut-être même de changer de mains six
mois après notre grande opération à
pékin patrick clément analysent
maintenant les signes qui pourraient
sauver ce changement
la cinquième symphonie affaire
par un orchestre chinois c'était le 8
octobre 79 points qu'elle se vendra
exceptionnelle en direct de pékin
le fait quand elle veut et pu réaliser
une journée en direct de chine signifier
déjà la mort du changement c'était la
plus qu'un signe une preuve le
gouvernement chinois en acceptant de
montrer une partie de son pays en direct
à des étrangers démontré que le réalisme
primés et que les réflexes précédent
était en folie mais dépassée
quelques jours auparavant en plein
centre de pékin ont chanté
l'internationale
une manifestation tolérée mais oui par
le gouvernement peut-être pas partout le
gouvernement mais sûrement par cette
tendance que deng xiaoping représente
vive le peuple crie l'un des
organisateurs de cette la volonté sur
cette tendance ne se montrait quelque
peu libérale quelque peu mais pas plus
mais alors que tout est fait ici pour
que disparaissent les tories les
réflexes les images propres notes s'est
tous mis à ses fidèles ont conduit
encore chaque semaine tout un peuple
résigné mais sceptique devant la
dépouille de celui qui n'est vraiment
maintenant qu'un souvenir aux contours
que l'on veut de plus en plus indécis
thank you pigné c'est sûr pour quelque
chose il ne veut pas affronter
directement l'ex images fédératrice en
résumant ces phénomènes qui apparaissent
parfois contradictoires on arrive à la
conclusion que thank you une ici bien
dallaire a réussi maintenant à infiltrer
douchement l'appareil du parti
tous ou presque qui s'était compromis
pendant la révolution culturelle ont
disparu tous sauf rakoff a alors de
nouveau plaint en chine ni des d'une
nouvelle et curation en chinois nous ont
appris depuis longtemps à faire
disparaître comme par miracle
toute une partie de leur histoire
bientôt un pan d'histoire même très
proches pourraient être gommé une
certitude
cela ne concernera pas d'intérêt
quelques savas qui encore la répression
ir soir le porte parole de la charte des
77 et sept autres personnes ont été
arrêtés alors qu'ils participent à une
conférence au domicile de l'un des
signataires de la charte
cambodge les riel vont réapparaître
cette monnaie remplacera le riz que
certains capitalisées et limitera donc
l' économie de troc c'est la preuve que
la vie commence à renaître dans ce pays
demain dans ce journal nous vous
présenterons à remarquable document d'un
quart d'heure signé edwards lors et
alain st il y a des enfants aujourd'hui
au cambodge il ya beaucoup d'enfants y
compris des enfants de moins de cinq ans
il n'y a plus de famine aujourd'hui au
cambodge du moins con instant la famine
celle dont on meurt il y a des
vietnamiens aujourd'hui au cambodge
beaucoup de vietnamiens qui sont ils que
veulent t'ils nous donc passé deux
semaines
quinze jours avec alain st et
jean-claude vargas au coeur même du
cambodge sans parti pris en essayant
d'oublier tout ce qu'on nous avait dit
ce qui est bien ce qui est mal parce
qu'on est de droite ou parce qu'on est
de gauche
nous avons demandé à sillonner toutes
les routes du cambodge sans restriction
en terminant par cette merveilleuse
région des temples d'angkor fermé
pendant plus de quatre ans au monde
comme leur a été le cambodge lui-même
avec tous les éléments que nous allons
ramener
nous allons essayer je le répète sans
parti pris
le reconstituer une journée passée au
cambodge
demain soir donc à 20 heures retour en
france pour cette dernière information
un petit peu alarmante
jean paul sartre 74 ans se trouve depuis
quelques heures au service de
réanimation de l'hôpital broussais à
paris à suite d'un début de deyme
pulmonaire mais vint l'instant me fait
savoir dans son entourage
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude la dissolution
du conseil municipal de vestric et
candiac dans le gard a été prononcée
hier par le conseil des ministres le
maire de la commune réclamait la
fermeture d'un établissement vous
souvenez pour handicapés belge mise en
liberté provisoire de plaine en scraire
acceptée par la courte cour d'appel de
rennes il avait été condamné par le
tribunal de quimper pour avoir jeté des
pierres sur les forces de l'ordre lors
de manifestations anti nucléaire à
plogoff
et puis hier nous vous annoncions
d'enlèvement de la femme d'un industriel
belge à proximité de cagnes-sur-mer bien
madame se dore a été libéré quelques
heures seulement après son enlèvement
sans que les ravisseurs et obtenu de
rançon puis un autre enlèvement hier
aussi d'un petit garçon de 8 ans cette
fois dijon son père est ouvrier a trouvé
sous la porte de l'appartement familial
un mot griffonné en arabe dans lequel
les ravisseurs demandent une rançon de
trois millions de francs le petit
mohamed qui a disparu est l'aîné de
quatre enfants football quarts de finale
des coupes d'europe hier soir seul
nantes vous le savez s'est qualifié face
à dynamo de moscou puisque saint-etienne
et les strasbourgeois ont été éliminés
sans grand panache
alors thierry roland n'a envie de savoir
que sont les chances des lampes et pour
la suite des opérations
je crois qu'il faut d'abord tirer un
grand coup de chapeau au football club
de nantes vainqueur de la coupe de
france qui est donc le dernier club
qualifié et qui se trouve qualifié avec
du beau monde puisque arsenal équipe
londonienne valence club espagnol et la
juventus de turin seront les adversaires
de nantes au niveau des demi finales
nantes connaîtra son adversaire samedi
soir à l'issue d'un tirage au sort qui
aura lieu en suisse comme d'habitude et
je crois que quel que soit l'adversaire
de nantes ce sera un dur morceau mais
que les nantais sont capables d'avaler
car déjà d'être dans les quatre derniers
c'est un bel exploit
alors on va revoir ce cas était
l'exploit précisément d'hier ils ont été
battus mais quel beau but celui là
oui je crois que henri michel a prouvé
hier aux téléspectateurs et aux
spectateurs de son pain qu'il était un
des meilleurs footballeurs d'europe par
ce premier tir que pil bouille détourne
en corner et surtout par ce but de la
43e minute signé de ce grand capitaine
l'un des plus brillants et des plus
constants parmi les footballeurs
français 32 ans 57 sélections en équipe
de france et pourtant henry n'a jamais
été aussi un but merveilleux qui a remis
le football club de nantes en scène il
le fallait car la mi temps approchait et
d'autres groupes maintenant bien les
autres coupes je crois que l'on peut
dire que l'on retrouve vraiment tout le
gratin du football européen sauf
peut-être liverpool qui domine le
championnat anglais et l'inter de milan
qui est en tête du championnat d'italie
puisque dans la coupe des clubs
champions retrouvera à nottingham forest
le tenant hambourg qui est le champion
d'allemagne le real madrid qui a le plus
remporté la coupe d'europe et l'ajax
d'amsterdam qui a aussi gagné trois fois
cette compétition et dans la coupe de
l'union européenne trop stalmans puisque
ces quatre clubs ouest allemand le
bayern francfort mönchengladbach est
donc éliminé saint-etienne et stuttgart
qui se retrouveront au niveau des lui
final ça ne s'était jamais vu et je
crois que ça prouve la puissance du
football ouest allemand bien marché
retire il fait mois plusieurs accepter
cette rose personne n'en veut depuis le
début ces émissions mais pour lui donner
ou non en fait ce que je voulais y avait
peint un tiercé aujourd'hui à evry pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 7 le 13 et le
5 ces deux combinaisons rapporte 9846
francs pour 5 francs dans l'ordre et 12
211 francs dans un ordre différent
ce soir vous avez rendez vous avec paul
amar qui vous communiquera les dernières
nouvelles aux alentours de 23h et puis
demain c'est le communiste charles
lieberman qui sera le témoin de notre
édition de 12h45 et puis avant de finir
je vous rappelle les prévisions de
laurent broomhead pour demain un pro
vision assez pessimiste le temps sera
médiocre froid froid il pleuvrait
neigera voilà ce journal est terminée
bonsoir à tous et j'espère demain à 20h
vous rappelle que vous avez un rendez
vous avec un très très bon document d'un
quart d'heure sur le cambodge
aujourd'hui bonsoir